قبل ايام من انطلاق كاس العالم في صوره
انتشرت على المنصات وفعليا فجرت الانترنت
حول العالم وفي الغالب كلكم شفتوها فمسي
ورونالدو في صوره واحده او اعلان واحد
صوره ناس كثير للوحله الاولى اصلا شكر في
حقيقتها وقالت انه مفبركه وانه يعني اكبر
متنافسين في عالم كره القدم بيطلعوا سوا
اعلان واحد
مو معقول لكن الصوره اتضح انها صحيحه لو
انها فعلا اعلان مركز
الشهيره ويعني مجرد ظهور الاثنين في
الاعلان سواء خلك صار يعتبروا هذا الاعلان
اعلان اعلان الموسم لكن تفاصيل اضافيه
بدات تتضح شويه شويه واثبت انه الاعلان
فعليا تاريخي الصوره مثل ما شفته بيظهر
فيها رونالدو وميسي وهم بيلعبوا شطرنج
علشان
بيلعبوا من غير لوح شطرنج لانهم بيستخدموا
مربعات الشنطه اللي هو احد الت المعروفه
للملكه او للماركه كبديل للوحه الشطرنج
فكره انهم بيلعبوا مباراه ضد بعض فيها نوع
من الرساله عن التنافس الشديد بينهم خاصه
وانه يعني اكثر لاعبين في كره القدم في
انقسام حولهم مين الافضل فيهم ميسي ولا
رونالدو يعني في معسكرات خلف هذا ومعسكرات
ثانيه خلف هذا الناس تقول ميسي
تقول لا رونالدو هو
طيب فكره التنافس بينهم على مين الافضل
يعني ملعوبه في الاعلان بانهم بيتنافسوا
خاصه
لمحبين او لما تحديد المحبين قال شطرنج
كشفه معلومه لسه مفاجاه اكثر واكثر فترتيب
حجاره الشطرنج لاحظت الناس انه الناس
ترتيبهم في مباراه شطرنج شهيره
يعني ماغنسكارزون وهيكارو هناك مورا في
2017 واللي بيعتبروا اساطير شطرنج
والمباراه خلصت بالتعادل فكان الاعلان
مستخدم رساله التعادل هذه وبيلمح فيها
للتعادل او التساوي بين رونالدو وميسي
والمنافس الازليه حول مين الافضل واللي
للان ما تم حسمها اما اللفت الاخيره اللي
فعليا ملعوبه فهي في الشنطه اللي بيلعبوا
عليها الشنطه هذه هي الشنطه اللي بينقل
فيها كاس العالم نفسه
هما حاملين كاس العالم في باختصار الاعلان
كانه بيقول انه الاثنين للان في عالم كره
القدم متعادلين وفاضل الفاصل اللي بينهم
واللي بيلعبوا عليه حاليا وهو كاس العالم
هو الحلم اللي لسه حاجه للارجنتين ولا
رونالدو حجاج وقولي البرتغال فعليا اعلن
مجنون اللاعبين طبعا نشروا الصور على
حساباتهم مع تعليق واحد وهو النصر حاله
ذهنيه واشعروا للمصوره الشهيره اللي
ملتقطه الصوره وهي يعني
رجعوا كمان وننشره فيديو من كواليس تصوير
الاعلان وهنا كان في مفاجاه ثانيه وهي انه
اللاعبين ما كانوا حاضرين مع بعض وقت
التصوير كل واحد اتصور لوحده وبعدين
الصوره
هواوي
[موسيقى]
خريطه مانع
الصوره حديث الناس فعليا في كل مكان وحتى
رونالدو في مؤتمر صحفي على هامش كاس
العالم ان سال عنها ورد كان انه نفسي اكون
اللاعب اللي يقول لي ميسي كش ملك في كره
القدم
يندم الينا رئيس قسم التسويق في جامعه
الفيصل دكتور سعد الحقيل اهلا فيك معانا
دكتور سعد يعني الناس لما شافت الاعلان
انصدموا لي كثير اسباب بس يمكن واحده من
الاشياء انه الشركه بحجم ماركت الويفيتو
بحاجه انها تعمل اعلان من هذا النوع تستقط
فيه اثنين من اكبر نجوم العالم
بسم الله شكرا على الاستضافه ردا على
سؤالك اول شيء الاعلان يخلق قيمه
انطباع ولا انطباع شيء مطلوب ومرغوب من
ناحيه المستهلك
ومن ناحيه الشركه والانطباع لما يخلق قيمه
قيمه مرغوبه وسهل فاهمه لما نتكلم بشكل
عام علميا عن اهميه الاعلام بالنسبه
اغلب الشركات التي تحتاج فعلا الاعلام هذا
الجمال بهذا التخطيط بهذا الذكاء بهذا
الغموض الذي
شركات الموضه والاسيه ما اهمها نجحها على
اطلاقه
ان الاعلان والاعلان جدا رائع جدا الاسباب
كثيره الاستعراضها خلال هذا اللقاء ولكن
شركات الموضه دائما تحتاج الاعلان لان
المنتجات التي تفكير تعتمد كثيرا على
التواجد احنا اليوم بشكل ابسط نستغرب مثلا
ان ال بالعالم
فتواجدها في الاماكن المهمه في المناسبات
الكبيره زي كاس العالم مع النجوم والكبار
يعطي القيمه اللي تكلمنا عنها في بدايه
المداخ فالاعلان اذن للشركات الفخمه او
شركات الموضه اهم منا لاي شركه اخرى لانها
تبيعك قيمه
منك مش محتاجين بهذا الاعلان انه يقولوا
للناس تعالوا اشتروا اغراضنا هم بيعلنوا
عن قوه البراند نفسه مستمدين انه من الحدث
اللي هو كاس العالم ومن حجم النجوم
الجميله
زاد السلام
دائما الشركات الموضه او الشركات اللي
بتخصصه
لغايه الثمن تحتاج تكون متواجده مع خاص
بقمه النجاح
يعني نجمين على المستوى الرياضات كامله
يعني اكثر من قرن وهم دائما على الاعلام
اضيف بس نقطه واحده انا اعتقد انه اعلان
جدا مدروس وفي قاعده افريقيا تقول له
فريده راسك او الراكب المجاني يعني اعتقد
لو راحت سوت سبونسر لكاس العالم
مع استغلت الحدث بشكل عام وكلام الناس
يعني اليوم او من قبل امس تقريبا طفى
نغمات الحرب في الاعلام وصعد يعني نغمه
كاس العالم فتخيل كل شيء يحكي عن رونالدو
وميسي هم افضل او اكثر لاعبين الاعلام
يدرسونهم تقدر تسوي الترابط هذا بكاس
العالم مع علامه تجاريه انا اعتقد انها
واحد من اعظم الاعلانات يعني انت بتقول
انه كمان هما راحوا استفادوا من الضجه
الاعلاميه اللي صارت يعني كمان
نعرف انه حجم الكفر الاعلام
كم مره يكتبوا ميسي هيطلع على طول
المحركات البحث
رونالدو
طيب الاعلان زي ما ذكرنا وحضرتك ذكرت يعني
اعلان ذكي في كثير همم رسائل موجوده وكل
شويه بتطلع تفاصيل انه حتى لما ان هم
اللعيبه الشطرنج كانوا ماخذين نفس القعده
هذه الطاوله هي نفسها الاماكن
الاحجار الشطرنج وكل ده هذه الرسائل
المبطنه يعني مو كل احد هيفهمها هم ليش
مهتمين انهم يحطوها
جميل انا اعتقد الماركات ال ال ال الثمينه
والاعلانات الجيده والافلام حتى الافلام
الكويسه لازم يندرج في
السيناري بحقها جزء عم
نتكلم عن تفاصيل التفاصيل التفاصيل انت
لما تشتري امر خارق او تذهب المطعم فخم
جدا جدا تهتم بكل التفاصيل
هذه مطلوبه لانجاح الاعلان السوري او
القصه زي ما اتفضلتي انت سردتيها الاهم من
كده انهم قاعدين يلعبون على الشنطه
الرئيسيه لتنقل كاس العالم بمعنى اللي
هيفوز منهم هياخذ الكاس اللي جوه الشنطه
مرتبط بالعلامه التجاريه ارتباط كلي ومفعل
اكبر نجمين همم القصه مربوطه باثر يعني
معروف اللي هي التنافس الكبير اللي همم
يعني كل التفاصيل في متناغمه وكل يوم
اكتشافك اكتشاف الناس اللي اسرار بالكوشي
اه ممتع صح ان الجلسه كل شويه بتتكشف
التفاصيل وجهاسين بيتداولوها وزي ما قلت
هذا اصلا كمان بيزيد التغطيه حول هذا
الموضوع نحنا بنشكرك على هذه المعلومات
كان معنا رئيس قسم التسويق في جامعه
الفيصل دكتور سعد الحقيل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]